vous avez toujours les bras pensant oui
mais mais mais mais mais un petit
exemple quand monsieur trudeau est mort
et que je voulais aller me recueillir
moi j'ai vu que c'était un show puis
j'ai vu fidel castro sur le parvis où je
dis mes fidèles ils vont me reconnaître
si j'étais allé chanter moins qu'avant à
la vente par doit avant tout sur le toit
de des hlm mon ami fidèle et cetera il
va me sauter d'un bras mais j'étais
vice-président d'unibroue justesse une
conseil j'avais le choix ou faire des
affaires à cuba ou aux états unis
j'ai dit oh là peut-être c'est quand on
est quand on dans le temps d'unibroue je
pouvais pas dire n'importe quoi parce
qu'il y avait des employés une centaine
d'employés qui dépendaient de moi cetera
puis mes partenaires d'andré diocèse
racines là bas voilà je fais attention à
tout et maintenant non je suis
complètement les paiements par les bleus
j'ai toujours été un penseur original
mais je dirais que ne pas dire quelque
chose c'est déjà parlé c'est déjà parlé
beaucoup mais j'ai déjà commandé
j'aime pas marcher sur le seul break
comme on dit il faut dire tout ce qu'on
pense à eux
j'aime les gaffes j'aime quand les
politiciens font des gaffes aussi ça
fait avancer les choses
sinon tout le monde se surveille c'est
la langue de bois pour tout le monde
qu'ils ont tort